i had a chance to get down there a
couple of weeks ago just to jump off the
football bandwagon for a second bryson
deshambo is going to have everybody
talking this week i'm just going to tell
you guys i saw some things that i've
never seen before on the golf course so
it'd be cool to watch we may see
something we've never seen before in the
nfl and that's a season that keeps going
and going and going if you can't get all
the games in so mike florio can you just
synthesize what the competition
committee and then the owners eventually
this week decided on how they'll handle
things if we don't stay on schedule the
rest of the way
well it's not finalized yet and the nfl
players association may have something
to say about this because there is a
duty to bargain with the union before
expanding the playoffs but the tentative
plan is simple
plan a get all 256 games played in 17
weeks and proceed with the 14 team
playoff field plan b
use an 18th weekend for any makeup games
and if you make them all up 14 team
playoff field plan c if you lose any of
the games despite that extra week of
makeup games that's when they go to the
16 team field now there's been some
caveats like they have to be meaningful
games that are lost and i don't know
what will ultimately flip the switch
on going to 16 teams but if any games
are lost that's when the possibility
arises of eight teams per conference
like they did back in 1982 when the
strike reduced the season to nine games
per team
tony roddy what do you think of that
coach you want to go first
yeah i'm hopeful that we do get to play
every game that that's what you want as
a competitor i'm glad we've got these uh
provisions in place but
let's just pray we get to play all the
games
and if i'm a player i'm i mean i'm
willing to play more playoff games
because i get opportunity to get a check
i get opportunity to get that exposure
and play in the playoffs while other a
lot of other teams are just sitting at
home so yeah if i'm a player i wouldn't
mind i'll definitely be open to playing
extra game
i think it's become more realistic
conversation we've seen the sec just
this week lose pretty much half of its
schedule so as the virus spreads in the
country it's naturally going to touch
the nfl a little bit more so we'll have
to watch that and then mike there was
part b of it regarding compensation for
teams that entertain and eventually get
more minority candidates to that step
before if not this step of hiring in the
interview process can you synthesize
what the outcome of that conversation
was for everyone
yes it's a reversal from something that
coach and i talked at length about
earlier this year when there was
consideration given to awarding
compensatory draft picks to teams who
hire minority coaches or minority
general managers now the reward goes not
to the team that makes the hire but to
the team that develops the candidate to
the point where he becomes attractive as
a coach or a gm with another team that
team if it employed the minority
candidate for two or more years gets two
third-round draft picks if and when that
person becomes a head coach or a gm with
another team so the incentive is now to
create a robust pipeline of diverse and
inclusive candidates and coach i've been
saying all week they need to get away
from employment at these lower jobs
based on who you know and who you're
related to and this is an incentive to
do that
it really is uh mike and i'm in favor of
this i did some work with the fritz
pollard alliance and we're kind of
working on tweaking this and it really
does make sense uh we know when you're
hiring people in those entry-level
positions a lot of times it goes to your
son or your nephew if i was there i'd
hire my son obviously uh but when you
think about that now hey i'm gonna hire
a quality control person on offense if i
can hire a young bright minority
candidate and five years from now we're
going to get a third round draft choice
that that might tip the scale a little
bit and cause me to think well maybe i
don't need to hire the first person i
see on this on this resume sheet or i
don't need to hire one of my relatives
let me do something for the team and
then that's gonna help that pipeline
that we all seem to be talking about
coach i don't know just sitting here
listening and just kind of just thinking
about everything to me it's i'm actually
insulted
because to me it's just insulting to
have to offer incentives for an
organization to hire somebody of color
or a black person and to me if we're
good enough to play on the field we're
good enough to do different things we're
good enough to be able to coach and get
into the front office and go in there
and change some of the policies and
things like that
and that's why it's so important and
that's why we root for raheem morris and
brian flores and mike tomlin that's why
we root for these coaches to have
success because if they don't have
success and they fail that's just
another excuse for the owners to come in
and say well we hired we gave him a
chance but of course the black coach
couldn't make it so that's why every
single week we root for these guys
no no question and that's rodney exactly
why i was kind of against the first uh
iteration we had of this of rewarding
that team that hired the coach because i
think you're absolutely right nobody
wants to come on that level but as you
look back on it i'll take you back to my
career as a coach i i come in in 1996
i'm a young head coach ready to go
trying to hire a staff and i know the
problems that young african americans
had getting started so i hired lovey
smith out of college and i hired herm
edwards uh when he wasn't in the nfl and
i knew that those guys could do it and
they needed to be in there but somebody
who doesn't have that mindset who
doesn't think well gosh these entry
level positions make a difference now
giving them some incentive and saying
you know what if you'll at least go out
there and investigate
and look for the best people somewhere
down the road your organization may
benefit so take your time
still hire the best people but you know
what there's some incentive to look
around and uh i think this is going to
help i really do
and coach and that's one of the reasons
why i respect you so much and so many
people across the league respect you so
much because you didn't you didn't get
to a point of success and you said
forget about everyone else you said you
know what i'm going to bring people
along i'm going to use my experience and
all the information that i know i'm
going to teach other people and empower
them and that's why i have so much
respect for you and that's why so many
other people whether it's players
coaches scouts they always talk to me
hey tell coach dungeon said hello
because they know what type of person
you are and that's what it's about
ultimately mike tarico ditto times a
thousand couldn't agree more with what
you said rodney can i just double back
to what you were talking about
the quota systems obviously
get people very uptight and very
concerned on both sides of it nobody
wants token assignments or token jobs
given
but this system hasn't worked
so they got to find something that's
going to work a bit better and i do love
the fact and tony for all the work that
your group did that you helped the fritz
pollard association group
do at least it gives some relatively
intelligent direction to
we are incentivizing you to do this and
to develop i agree you should be doing
it automatically but if the pipeline
doesn't get full with more candidates
people aren't going to get to the top
with a real chance to succeed
so i hear what you're saying i agree
with what you're saying but i also at
the same time think we can applaud
what's being done here because i do
think it's going to give more minorities
a real chance and more importantly
head coaches owners the establishment in
the league which has been largely white
men
the opportunity to develop these guys
and the incentive to develop and guess
what they're going to realize we can
develop anybody who looks in any color
or shape or anything else good tony
you're gonna say something i'm sorry and
mike yeah i'm gonna interrupt rodney
here for a little bit and just say what
hopefully this will get across to people
in the nfl this is good for all of us
this is going to make for a better
league uh when i go back to 1996 i can
tell you i got criticized i got killed
in the tampa media
lovie smith who is that where is he from
herm edwards he's not coaching in the
league we need some experience i hired
mike tomlin when he was 29 years old
where did he come from university of
cincinnati nobody was on these guys when
you could see they were talented and
when they got in and got a chance to
show what they could do it was just a
couple of years when everybody was
beating down the door trying to get
these guys but getting that opportunity
and getting people to say you know what
let's think outside the box let's get
away from uh people we think are
candidates and give some people an
opportunity who are really bright and
let's see what they can do and hopefully
this will help that
mike i appreciate you saying what you're
saying and coach explaining it even more
it gives me a better understanding yeah
i have some underlying feelings because
i just don't think that we're less than
i get tired of people thinking that
because we're black men that we're less
than we work hard we have knowledge
we're smart we study we prepare we do
all those different things but i
appreciate that perspective because from
both of you guys because it gave me
something different to look at thank you
and rod and rodney i i think the most
important thing and let's not get too
far away from where we were as a country
in may
the number one thing we need to do is
listen right we need to listen and
understand more and by you expressing
how you feel about it helps me
understand it better and see it better
so the most important thing we can all
do we don't have to all agree but at
least if we listen and understand i know
how you feel about it i understand how
people feel marginalized that you're
a female or an african american or of
this race or this gender or anything
else so we have to have one of you in
the group no you want to be there
because of your merits and your talents
and your abilities so it's a difficult
line but it's it's opportunity and if
the door of opportunity opens i have a
friend who is the second generation in
sports media who said
my last name opened the door for me
there's no doubt about it but it's my
responsibility to keep the door open to
walk through that door and to succeed
and open the door for people behind me
and i love that because that's this
opportunity is for a lot of folks mike
florian i'll give you the last word on
this before we uh move back to the field
well i think back to 2002 when the nfl
passed the rooney rule under threat of
litigation from the late johnny cochran
and cyrus mary and
that worked at least that effort worked
to get the rooney rule passed because it
was so bad and it was so much worse than
than now but 18 years later it really
isn't in the grand scheme of things all
that much better so the league doing
what it has to do to try to improve the
pipeline and i really do think that's
the key guys it's the pipeline
the more candidates in the pipeline the
more that naturally the best will rise
to the top regardless of skin color
regardless of background regardless of
anything that pipeline just needs to be
more robust
and we've seen that coaching fellowships
play coaches who come to training camps
to learn to be around the nfl then go
back to their college jobs hopefully all
of this continues to get it forward to a
better and a more equitable place uh
let's talk ball on the field guys we've
we're past the halfway point here so now
we're we've done a little bit of
separating of who is who i want to go
through four divisions and see where
you're thinking and tony i'll start with
you and i'll start out west in the nfc
west where maybe it's a little upside
down from what we thought it would be at
the start of the year
well it is and i guess the word is look
out for arizona they're probably the
team that's a little better than we
thought they would be san francisco the
injuries have just hit them i don't know
if they can recover from that seattle
got off to the hot start i worry about
their defense the rams may be the most
complete team in that division um we'll
have to see how their quarterback plays
down the stretch in these big games but
uh watch out for arizona i think
i would say in the nfc west i like um
the rams i think offensively i'm very
comfortable with what they do they can
score points i think they have the best
defense in the division but when you
when you talk about arizona to me
they're just a little disappointing
because you see losses to the lions you
see losses to the panthers and their
defense is kind of up and down and kyler
he's exciting he's outstanding he can do
a lot of different things but he's still
a young quarterback so when i look at
that division i like the rams uh mike
florio
and the rams had the best weekend of
anyone in the division because they
didn't play so they couldn't lose
everybody else lost
right so the rams are right there but if
there was only one team i could watch
any given week it would be the cardinals
because of kylie murray he is so
exciting he's so dynamic and their games
are are typically very entertaining
and they're right there one game behind
the seahawks they hold the preliminary
tiebreaker they'll play seattle again
soon i believe it's a thursday night
game coming up within a few weeks but i
think arizona's got the talent if they
can just hold it together make good
decisions you know when you run the ball
on fourth and short don't go in shotgun
formation how are you going to get
fourth and short on shotgun and let kyla
murray run the ball and don't kick a
49-yard field goal if your guy can't
make it to the crossbar
so
well if they can iron some of that out
if they can iron some of that out of the
back half of the season maybe they could
take the division
just one last capri point here seattle
plays at the rams this week arizona that
following week like you were talking
about mike i think a lot of the pivoting
for the positioning post thanksgiving
will be determined in the nfc west the
next couple of weeks rodney that arizona
defense misses chandler jones you know
he he was right there at the top of the
league in sacks and that guy to get
pressure on the quarterback is missing
in big spots and let's see cliff
kingsbury and kyler murray now on the
big stage a bigger stage where games are
more important you have to prove
yourselves in year two can you handle
these games where this much makes a
difference in win or loss let me flip
this rodney and take the team that beat
arizona in a late exciting game last
week and that's miami over in the afc
east miami
buffalo
okay rodney for your interest i'll keep
the patriots in the conversation as well
you don't have to
who do you like
man that's a tough one and i know every
week you hear coach and i we're talking
about the miami dolphins and
you know what i like i like i like you
talking about to win the division or to
possibly get in the playoffs yes win the
division let's go come on i would have
to do it i would have to give you i'm
gonna say i'm gonna say buffalo at this
point just because josh allen and just
having more experience in tour and you
know what i was really impressed with to
a coach from week one to week two just
the progression the confidence
everything that he did rolling out uh
making people miss taking hits throwing
the ball down the field i thought he
looked phenomenal from week one to week
two
yeah and i'm gonna agree with you and
pick buffalo but if the season were 20
weeks long
i i think i might lean towards miami i
love their defense i love the toughness
that brian flores has brought to that
team i think two is going to grow look
out for miami next year i think they've
got a
really really good shot to make the
playoffs this year i think buffalo wins
it but look out for miami in 21-22-23
i'm still concerned about the bill's
running game now against the seahawks
they didn't try to use it very much and
the seahawks didn't plan accordingly as
pete carroll admitted after the game but
josh allen snapped out of whatever that
was you know when they got hit in the
mouth by the titans and they lost to the
chiefs i think they lost some confidence
they gradually built it back and now
they're riding a wave after beating the
seahawks they have to go to arizona
what snapped them out of it was the
seattle defense
the seattle defense snapped him out of
him that's true
that's true but you know i i think miami
is that team that the way they've won
and and they've been you know they've
been 43 to 17 over the 49ers and smack
down the rams and and going on the road
and beating a good arizona team i i
think miami's the one that can kind of
sneak up on the outside and take it but
i will say this about the patriots we
talked earlier about the playoff field
expanding to 16. i think whoever gets
the one seed in the afc doesn't want
that if the eighth seed ends up being
the patriots that's not the team you
want coming in with nothing to lose in a
wild card round when you otherwise going
to be sitting home on the couch watching
football that weekend now you got to
play a patriots instead of getting your
bye week no thank you
mike stop it stop but nobody's sitting
hold on hold on hold on stop it stop it
nobody sit listen nobody's sitting at
home with the number one seed oh my god
i'm really worried about the patriots
like stop it like what are you trying to
create i know there's a little
level over come on
oh wait a minute bill belichick single
elimination
i i i would much rather have that week
off that's my point give me the buy
so you're saying if if i'm kansas city
if i'm kansas city i'm sitting and i'm
andy reid i'm over here scared to death
because of bill belichick who hasn't
played one play in the last 30 years or
i'm not afraid of the patriots i want
the patriots this is when you want the
patriots and that's the thing about the
patriots nobody feels sorry for the
patriots every single week teams are
going to come out and try to kick their
butts because that's exactly what the
patriots have been doing the last two
decades so nobody feels sorry for the
patriots if i'm kansas city i definitely
want the patriots
yeah we saw the last last week
this is a do or die game for the
patriots
sam darnold the quarterback of the jets
is not playing the jets best defensive
player is not playing and it took a
miraculous rally and some
bad play by the jets down the stretch to
give new england a chance to win that
game yeah i i just don't see the same
new england team that we've seen in the
past rodney
agree with all that but you can't kill
them
they still find a way so wait till
sunday night when you all pick the
ravens just wait just just wait for that
stay tuned for that
let me wrap up with this guys two quick
ones the nfc and the afc south
uh after what you saw sunday night in
the game between tampa and new orleans
rodney do you think clear advantage new
orleans now
listen guys i told you last week i asked
you guys all a question i said are we
overrating tampa bay didn't i ask you
guys that oh no and maybe we're
overrating them and i got caught up in
the hype too you see the names on the
jersey and automatically sometimes you
feel like it's going to automatically
snap nah and me and coach we talked
about this last week it takes time to
continue to build that continuity in
chemistry and i just say this is my last
point i'm gonna tell you who has the
most to prove it's bruce arians what has
he done the last three years he's been
average seven eight and one eight and
eight seven and nine so we talk about
tom brady and these players and a b no
it's bruce ariens that has a lot to
prove because he's got all the weapons
he's got a top defense he's got all
these weapons he's got the quarterback
he wants now let's see if you can make
it work instead of getting blown out on
national television
yeah i agree the
tampa bay buccaneers didn't show what i
thought they were going to show on
sunday night but
new orleans has been a little up and
down too they've had some tough games
and games where they didn't show it so
let's see how it comes down the stretch
i will say this michael thomas and
emmanuel sanders make a big difference
when you give drew brees that weaponry
if those guys can stay healthy i think
they're going to have the edge in the
nfc south afc south yes
i don't know i'll give that one to mike
florio
yeah afc south i think it comes down to
what we see on thursday night between
the colts and the titans whoever wins
that game establishes the edge in the
their two games per year series and that
team's going to be the favorite but in
the nfc south look if they
as you said coach they have michael
thomas and emmanuel sanders they keep
them healthy they use taysom hill the
way they used him on sunday night to
keep the defense on its heels and and
ready to get out of the way when that
guy's running at you full speed ahead
but the one flaw continues to be not
getting the ball down the field in the
passing game they're going to come
against the team in the playoffs at some
point that takes away everything
underneath and forces them to try to
throw it over the top and unless they're
willing to put the ball and take some
hills hands repeatedly they're not going
to get the ball 30 40 yards down the
field and that could be the thing that
kills them
good rodney
yeah one of the things guys that you're
missing it's all offensive talk but
defensively this was really an
impressive game to me because they're
able to create pressure with the front
four and even every week we see marshawn
lattimore and all those guys getting
beat blowing coverages they didn't in
the secondary and that that's a big help
when you're out there competing against
some of the best offenses in the league
and i thought about that rodney as we
were watching the game
that you have tell me said for 12 years
to play tom brady you have to rush get
pressure on him with that front four and
play tight man-to-man coverage they had
the formula sunday night and it worked
in perfection
amen i i've said this a few times so i
apologize for repeating it but dennis
allen's done a really good job with that
new orleans defense over the last couple
of years remember you know the saints it
was like they had to outscore everybody
they can win these these slugf these
slugfest right now so uh we mentioned
the afc south real quick rodney tony let
you guys get in as the last word of the
afc south
if i had to favor a team it would
probably be the tennessee titans just
for the simple fact when you watch
philip rivers
the offense is very limited they have
some really good young weapons good
young running back but they're limited
in what they can do offensively because
he's a statue he's back there there's
guys open but he cannot you know create
more time to to make plays down the
field so i like ryan tannehill because
he can scramble and move around a little
bit coach
yeah i love indy's defense i think
they're a little bit better than
tennessee but i worry about phillip
rivers the big turnover at the wrong
time and i think that's going to be the
key in this thursday night game coming
up
you know can phillip rivers avoid the
the big turnover at the wrong time
you know tennessee's offensive line was
so good taylor lawn out for the year
they couldn't get the guys who they were
looking for derek henry's yards per
carry it not what it was the the uh the
the dump truck then would you upgrade
him to tony from a dump truck two f-150
he was rolling
we're gonna we're gonna since toyota's
our halftime sponsor we're gonna get
into like a toyota tundra we'll get you
to switch
monster
spot we're responsible no no that's
chevy we're gonna go toyota's hundreds
that that's that's what ronnie is trying
to get wheels in your hands man but um
[Laughter]
they need to they need to have that
for johnny smith and everything else and
not to put it on tannehill and that's
what i'm really gonna watch with them
the next couple of weeks can they figure
it out uh up front lastly guys let me
get thought from everyone on our
thursday on our monday the sunday night
game any any night of the week you
picked baltimore against new england
obviously we just talked about the
patriots uh rods will start with you
with the ravens as you look at them
going into the business part of the
season two back from pittsburgh but
pittsburgh is not uh a team that you
can't see losing games you can see
situations where now pittsburgh isn't
going to run through everyone so what do
you think about the ravens
um
still trying to figure them out mike and
i think they're still trying to figure
out their offense but for the patriots
the number one thing will have to be
stopping lamar in this run game i know
coach is going to play a lot more
man-to-man coverage he's got to load the
box and try to stop him last year they
couldn't stop him with with patrick
chung and hightower and all those guys
and now you're playing a bunch of young
guys i'm really concerned about them
being able to stop the run game i mean i
anticipate baltimore be running 30 plus
times on at at least because they they
can't stop the run
and i i would agree with you this game
is going to come down to who does stop
the run and then if the run does get
stopped does cam newton make the plays
or does lamar jackson who do you have
more confidence in and i agree with you
rodney the patriots secondary is
tremendous but that might not even be a
factor if they can't stop them from
running the football we may not even
hear about those secondary guys during
the course of the game
you know when i talked to john harbaugh
after the win over the colts and maybe
there's a little bit of a lou holtz
flavor to what he was saying but he did
seem to be concerned that it's the
patriots it's still bill belichick you
have to be ready and he's got a young
team you know they've established
themselves so well over the past couple
of years we forget this is a young team
for the most part they're still learning
how to win
big games they beat the patriots last
year when the patriots were undefeated
now they have to do it when they're the
one that's supposed to win the game
that's going to be the challenge to hold
it together and stay focused and not
think about the next nbc game on the
horizon for the ravens a couple of weeks
from now when they get the steelers
again in pittsburgh
well it's week 10 we're starting to
think about matchups who can make the
playoffs you saw steve kornacki our
friend from msnbc with the board we're
old school man we got we got the games
so here we go it's that time of year
getting excited for that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports